since the coronavirus knocked the lights
out on Broadway many stars of the stage
have turned to entertaining audiences
online only on CBS this morning we're
sharing the world premiere of a very
special collaboration our dr. Jon LaPook
shows us how beautiful it is to have
friends like this as social distancing
keeps us apart artists across the globe
are doing what they've always done bring
us together
on march 12th as the Great White Way
went dark a light bulb lit up in the
head of Grammy Award winner Jason
Howland the musical director for the
Broadway head beautiful
so many of us aren't doctors and nurses
and can't be on the front lines and we
want to support those people as much as
we can and one of the things we know how
to do is share our gifts and try to
spread a little joy whipped up some
hearts I think it was just kind of a
no-brainer woman Jessie Mueller who
showed the minutes closed days before
opening night won a Tony Award playing
the role of Carol Kane here's this
beautiful message that this amazing
woman has written and let's let's remind
the world though that we are in this
together
[Music]
eighty previous cast members and
musicians from beautiful productions all
over the globe are featured in this
performance that benefits the Actors
Fund this is why we will put on the
planet to connect people Tony Award
winner Brian Stokes Mitchell who is now
recovering from Kovac 19 with heads up
the nonprofit entity which helps support
actors and many others in need it's the
camera people it's the writers it's the
the producers on the show
it's the grips and the gaffers and the
sound people we are all kind of gig
workers workers and entertainment who
like so many people around the globe
find themselves wondering what tomorrow
will bring
[Music]
and during this difficult time a
worldwide community of artists
professional and amatuer is stepping
forward
[Music]
mariachi bear and producer James Wesley
and his husband musician set Radetzky
launched a webcast stars in the house
streams live twice a day and features
performances from Broadway's biggest
stars I'm there too as a medical
consultant but on occasion I get to wear
a different pack three point seven
million times Tony winner Laura Benanti
launched sunshine songs to provide a
stage for high school students who shows
were canceled
she's received thousands of videos so
many messages from people saying this is
my only bright spot right now my only
bright star these moments are moving
audiences and artists alike all of us
eager for better days ahead having a
quarantine now 4:18 a something like
that I'm in touched another person
that's so weird now that's true for all
of us
for CBS this morning dr. Jon LaPook I
have to say Anthony those videos musical
videos singing videos never ever get old
to me really it does feel like a big hug
every time I see one it's true it feels
like a big hug and we learned how to say
Jon LaPook name LaPook yeah I see and
who knew Jon LaPook is a frustrated
singer I didn't know that about him Oh
[Music]